[Música]
recuerdo hace un par de años atrás bueno
ya hace bastantes años mientras recogía
mi pequeño andrew leonardo a la salida
de la escuela como es mi costumbre
me dijo con lágrimas en los ojos y con
un tono cargado de angustia mami no
quiero que sigas hablando más de sexo
me quedé sorprendida como un pequeñito
de 6 años me decía eso
pero lo que más me impactó pues su
argumento al porque él no quería que yo
hablara más de esto
me dijo dos mujeres y las mujeres no
deben hablar de sexo
realmente impactada con lo que me decía
mi único hijo
pero también motivada tenía que
demostrarle a mi hijo y no solo a mi
hijo a la sociedad en general
que si es importante hablar de sexo y
por qué hablar de sexualidad no es algo
exclusivo de hombres
en nuestro país debido a la falta de
educación sexual que existe el
porcentaje de pobreza ha aumentado
dramáticamente y esto se ve reflejado en
el último informe de 2017 mundos aparte
que publica el fondo de población de las
naciones unidas en donde nos indica que
el embarazo en adolescentes es la
muestra más clara de desigualdad y
pobreza
según datos oficiales de onusida más del
60% de nuestros jóvenes no utilizan
ningún tipo de protección al momento de
sus relaciones sexuales y fíjense que
aunado a estos porcentajes de pobreza
que nos indica el fondo de población de
naciones unidas
de los casi 9 millones de habitantes en
nuestro país el 60% vive en situación de
pobreza
cinco de cada diez hogares en extrema
y seguimos ocupando en segundo lugar en
américa latina con mayor incidencia de
niñas embarazadas
debido a la
aprende lo que esto es una palabra clave
aprende porque nos conviene saber de
sexualidad humana porque es algo
inherente a la esencia del ser humano es
algo que nos acompaña desde el momento
en que nacemos y continuará con nosotros
hasta el último de nuestros días
homosexuales y sexuados desde el momento
en que nacemos y el desconocimiento de
algo tan fundamental y tan delicado como
es la sexualidad nos está ocasionando
graves problemas en todas las edades
según reportes del ministerio público en
el país
un menor es ha usado cada ocho horas
esta estadística corresponde únicamente
a los casos que son denunciados tomemos
en consideración que en el abuso sexual
de niños en su mayoría no están
conscientes de ese abuso sexual no saben
que están siendo víctimas de abuso
sexual y tienden a vivir ese abuso por
años
y lo más aberrante de todo esto es que
se da en el círculo familiar y social
cercano a la víctima padres hermanos
tíos primos o amistades muy cercanas y
aún así nos preguntamos cuándo es el
momento de hablar
cuando es el momento de la gran charla
el momento es ya reconocer que en la
primera infancia
que va desde los 0 a los 8 años
el niño tendría que conocer cuáles son
las diferencias significativas entre un
hombre y una mujer saber de higiene de
cuidados conocer cuál es el verdadero
nombre de sus genitales que por cierto
no es palomita no es pajarito no es
pancito o cosita
es vagina desde en ese momento nos
enseñan a sentirnos avergonzados de algo
tan natural como son nuestros genitales
no nos da pena hablarles de las manos de
las rodillas de los pies pero si los
hacemos sentirse avergonzados por tener
un pene y una vagina ese tipo de
pensamiento fomenta el morbo
pero también en esta primera infancia
tendríamos que hablar con nuestros hijos
que aprendan a distinguir lo que es una
caricia buena de una caricia mala que
aprendan a reconocer
y abuso sexual y sobre todo que sepan a
quién recurrir si notan que algo raro
está pasando con ellos de algún extraño
o algún adulto está haciendo algo que
los hace sentir incómodos
a medida que nuestros hijos crecen y se
acercan a la pubertad es hora de empezar
a familiarizarnos con el desarrollo
psicosexual con qué es lo que va a
suceder con su cuerpo a medida que ellos
crecen
porque es que resulta ser que las
hormonas empiezan a hacer su empieza a
desarrollarse entonces hacen su labor
fisiológica la mayor parte de los niños
a esta edad
experimentan los famosos sueños húmedos
las erecciones nocturnas las
eyaculaciones los orgasmos mientras
duermen y se sienten culpables
avergonzados pensando que es algo que
ellos pueden controlar
y les dijo que esto iba a pasar quién
les dijo que esto era absolutamente
normal y que era únicamente el reflejo
de que sus hormonas empezaban a hacer su
trabajo
pero también se hacía frecuente
necesario y muy importante el
autoerotismo o la masturbación como
constantemente le llamamos que por
cierto no causa ceguera
no te deja infértil no altera tus
capacidades mentales únicamente te
permite conocerte mejor descargar la
atención sexual típica de la edad
a medida que crecen nuestros hijos
y se acercan a la tan temida
adolescencia
resulta ser que se vuelve más importante
la cercanía de los padres con los hijos
no solo para afianzar el vínculo
afectivo con ellos sino también para
reforzar la autoestima y para brindarles
la información adecuada acerca del
inicio
acerca del inicio de la vida sexual
porque resulta ser que nuestros jóvenes
están siendo más sexualmente activos de
lo que nosotros como padres nos
imaginamos se estima que antes de los 15
años nuestros jóvenes están iniciando
sexualmente
y como les decía antes según datos
oficiales de onusida más del 60% de
estos jóvenes no utilizan ningún tipo de
protección al momento de sus relaciones
sexuales
este sitio perdón esta situación está
ocasionando graves problemas
tendríamos en esta etapa que empezar a
hablar de infecciones de transmisión
sexual
de embarazo precoz de método de
planificación familiar métodos de
protección recordemos que nuestros
jóvenes están siendo bombardeados de
muchísima publicidad de muchísima
información que lejos de educar corrompe
están teniendo acceso a la pornografía
porque está al alcance de un clic en sus
dispositivos móviles se estima que más
del 43 por ciento de todo lo que
encontramos en internet es pornografía y
la pornografía nos está ocasionando
adicciones sexuales
aborto precoz en nuestros adolescentes
comportamientos sexuales de riesgo no
solo en los jóvenes también en los
adultos
hoy más que nunca debemos hablar debemos
reconocer que la sexualidad es mucho más
que sexo
el desconocimiento de esta situación nos
va a ocasionar múltiples problemas a
todas las edades porque por increíble
que parezca en pleno siglo 21 también
las parejas son víctimas del
desconocimiento y de los prejuicios
conócete
vamos a ver voy a adelantar un poco la
diapositiva porque no me está
funcionando
en este escrito que
con 11 p la siguiente por favor
y la siguiente
conócete a medida escucho en la clínica
a muchas mujeres decir
no me gusta el sexo
que sólo él lo disfruta
nunca me ha dado un orgasmo
cuando lo que deberíamos hacer es
conocernos más y mejor estar conscientes
de esto para saber qué es lo que podemos
pedir que es lo que disfrutamos qué es
lo que nos agrada lamentablemente en
nuestra sociedad el concepto de la mujer
decente está aunado a la ignorancia
aquella mujer que tenga la osadía de
mostrarse muy conocedora de aspectos
sexuales es etiquetada como liberal
inmoral es la típica mujer que
cualquiera quiere disfrutar pero muy
pocos respetar
pero también por contraparte nos
encontramos a caballeros que creen que
deben saberlo todo en torno al
comportamiento sexual tienen que ser
siempre expertos aman
tienen que conocer tanto de anatomía
femenina incluso más que nosotros porque
claro es un instinto quien se supondría
que hay que enseñarles a ellos cómo
hacerlo ese tipo de pensamiento está
ocasionando que muchas personas vivan
mintiendo vivan la vida sexual
sintiéndose cosas u objetos viendo en la
intimidad el tedio de una actividad más
que cumplir así como de barrer trapear
en el sexo planchar etcétera
se nos olvida
y es algo inherente a nuestra esencia
que tendríamos que disfrutar
constantemente escucho a caballeros que
dicen
se quejan del escaso interés que sus
mujeres le exponen a los escasos
encuentros íntimos que ahora tienen y
dicen es que es frida que como que no
disfruta a saber si es que no me quiere
o estará con otro porque no se preguntan
qué quiere esa mujer que disfruta esa
mujer estará sintiendo lo mismo que yo
siento lo estará disfrutando tanto como
lo disfruto yo
este tipo de cuestionamientos de verdad
que nos ahorrarían múltiples problemas
nos ahorrarían múltiples disfunciones
sexuales y nos enseñaría la urgencia de
hablar de sexo pero no de la típica
pornografía con la que muchos confunden
la sexualidad sino de aquella sexualidad
integral que te enseña a disfrutar te a
conocerte a recorrer cada zona de tu
cuerpo y aprender a disfrutar y
disfrutar la de tu pareja también como
ese regalo maravilloso que se nos ha
otorgado ese regalo que la naturaleza
nos asignó y la naturaleza nos dijo que
sólo ellos podrían disfrutarlo
en realidad debemos conocernos más y
mejor
debemos
aprender a pedir reconocer que sentir
placer no es pecado que experimentamos
placer no solo al momento de tener
relaciones sexuales sino también cuando
comemos cuando reímos
cuando dormimos y si es algo tan natural
porque sentir culpa
porque no estar consciente que es
nuestra responsabilidad sentirnos bien
sentirnos cómodos sentirnos amados y por
qué no decirlo disfrutar del sexo como
ese regalo maravilloso
a los que somos padres y madres de
familia atrevámonos a hablar con
nuestros hijos démonos cuenta que el
conocimiento es poder en ningún momento
el conocimiento va a hacer daño
si queremos
blindar a nuestros hijos y prevenir
abuso sexual
hablemos busquemos información que
refuercen nuestros conocimientos y nos
permita ser responsables con nuestros
hijos vamos a evitar también que se
inicien sexualmente de manera precoz esa
sexualidad adolescente que se inicia por
el arrebato de las hormonas por
desconocimiento o por curiosidad
a todos en general atrevámonos a vivir y
a disfrutar de la sexualidad a dejar a
un lado la creencia de que algo tan
natural algo tan bonito como es la
sexualidad puede dañar nos dejemos a un
lado los prejuicios
el morbo la culpa la pena y aventure
monos
a disfrutar nuestra vida sexual y para
los que se preguntan que puede que el
pequeñito de seis años que sentía pena
de que su mami hablar de sexualidad de
que su mami educada en un tema tan
sensible y no es para mujeres hoy por
hoy es un adolescente de 14 años y es mi
principal admirador mientras leonardo
muchas gracias